when you say foreign exchange that's
something that i think in crypto most
people just say uh either i'm in like
the crypto universe or i'm in the
bitcoin universe uh there's really not
any exchange between those two assets um
how do you think about foreign exchange
like what you guys can do for
corporations so circle just came out
with a euro stable coin as well right
and the markets are nowhere near as deep
as traditional finance for for forex is
you know very deep for the major
currencies
but feasibly if they get as deep
uh the trading pools for example between
like uscc usd euro
then you have a more efficient system
anything done on chain involves less pen
and paper less transaction costs 24 7
you know weekends you can have your
money
we definitely see that happening i mean
d5 definitely proved that it works in
this
downturn they were the ones who got paid
first you know they were senior on
everything uh from all the all the
crashes so
explain that more like there's
centralized finance there's
decentralized finance uh you said that
defy works and they got paid first what
do you mean yeah so some of the people
who pause withdrawals for example um
they had and they were borrowing from d5
protocols and if they didn't pay back
those loans they would have had their
collateral liquidated now in c5 there's
things like bank bankruptcy there's
cronyism there's favoritism etcetera d5
protocols are dumb in the best way
they're dumb in the best way which means
you can't call someone you get
liquidated if you don't actually you
know pay your interest pay your loan
back it's over and that's what you
actually saw on chain
there's no nonsense with them uh so
that's product market fit i mean
there's no question about people
rehypothecating or re-pledging
collateral in two different places for
example it's it's just you give the
collateral in the form of bitcoin to a
d5 protocol or eth
and you have to pay or you get
liquidated and that was that
transparency was so key in downturns
like this when i hear people say that
defy worked uh and c5 didn't uh i think
that it's probably too much of a like a
reductionist uh perspective of like uh
obviously luna ust you know those uh
that kind of ecosystem did not work uh
and then obviously on the centralized uh
side there's company you know take a
coin base right zero issue all that so
how do you think about c5 vs d5 given
what we've watched play out over the
last you know three four months so d5 i
think is very good at over
collateralized lending and borrowing
because it can automate a lot of that
that's not a giant market though
um
ultimately if more of this kind of
lending activity takes place on chain
it's more efficient and it's at lower
cost
so this world of kind of cd5 is coming
out which is really cfi but on chain
there are protocols like maple finance
for example that are doing that and
when you have these protocols on chain
you avoid pen and paper you avoid
telegram chats you avoid a lot of the
issues so there is certainly a place for
both d5 is doing very well and over
collateralized right now under
collateralize is a different story
uh i've seen people pitching underclaw
eyes on chain lending is that possible
and what are your thoughts in terms of
how viable that will be uh in the d5
world but without the overcloud it's
extremely hard and it's not viable like
it's in the long run it probably is but
what is missing is the regulatory aspect
i mean if someone doesn't pay you
unsecured
you have to go to court ultimately you
don't have my collateral if if that
happens
and so you need
we don't have you know police forces we
don't have court systems on chain right
now and there's no concept of credit
scores uh on chain so that's why
collateral is king on chain that's why
over collateralized lending is is the
first kind of lending that takes place
on chain so
when you have these kind of court
systems on chain or
you know regulatory bodies that
recognize that this is a loan on chain
and they come in and intervene that's
how you can do you know unsecured
lending or credit scores on chain you
just said collateral is king
when the finance world of wall street
kind of traditional system sees
collateral is king on chain
why don't they all just run and be like
oh my god we'll never lose money as long
as we have over collateralized lending
on chain yeah i mean because it's a very
small market that's not the point of
credit in most cases it's it's mostly
when you do collateralize lending it's
mostly for traders and there's margin
lending and stuff like that but that's
nowhere near i mean the entire financial
system runs on unsecured lending now
getting it on chain is going to be it's
going to be a longer process than most
people uh want to admit but the over
collateralized part is work is running
like a clock and that's what we should
be grateful for can you decentralize
unsecured lending in the sense where
reputation credit scores like all these
things that we know the centralized
system relies on whether they work
perfectly or not like that is how the
centralized system works uh if you look
at something like bitcoin the whole idea
is that hey we can build these banks
without rehypothecation we can we can
essentially go back to uh kind of a
strong financial system that isn't built
on this huge credit component
is
the idea of bringing unsecured lending
to
uh the d5 or like on chain uh world just
trying to recreate some of the problems
from the legacy system in the new world
or like how do you how do you just think
through
what are the pros and cons of doing that
look unsecured learning's gonna take
place whether it's
you know whether it's bitcoin whether
it's eth whether it's dollars
uh it can be done more efficiently when
you have basically an open api like a
compatible api everywhere which is on
chain
so it's going to happen whether whether
we believe in it or like it or not um
and yeah like things like decentralized
credit scores and stuff that's i mean
it could be the case we have big
problems with like oracle's right now
the truth is what we need isn't like
what you would want is enforcement if
someone doesn't pay you back and there's
no way to enforce it on chain currently
you need like someone to hold you
accountable a court system or something
like that and we're a long way from that
obviously